Hồi sơ cho thấy ổ ở một mình hả?
Thì rồi một món ăn, đối bỏng giảm sát, rồi sau đó tự dừng lại và bảo cho tự lợi giảm sát.
Kể ông đang bị giám trong phòng với hai mấy đương,
tại chủ sơ kẹn sát lên băng.
Hồi đông thường phản toàn của cao sẽ nhóm học,
trong ngày, hảm ơn ông thống mi một để xem sẽ vụ việc.
Nhóm được sự của ông thì tiếp tục đẹn nghĩ chuyện rằng của anh tuyên đạo vì lý gió sẽ quẻ.
Ông bố sương nâro là đối thủ chính trích thích liệt của đương kêm tổ thống Brasil,
Lú là đa XIV,
hát hành người trên cạnh này lù ở trong phy dịch bệnh đồng năm 2020,
tì vậy ông lại có một con hệ tốt,
với tổng thống mi của anh Trump,
người đã tự áp thử một xung lên nhiều một hàng Brasil,
để phản đối ăn tuy, hảm ơn bẩy năm của ông,
và mới chỉ vừa giữa bất thử được phát triệt bỏ,
cao phê và cao cao Brasil trong thời gian đầy.
Ló trưng mình ý trị trích việc phát triệt ông của Sonaro,
là dấu hiệu xuyệu pháp quyền trong khi tổng thống rút là đo xíu và bảo vệ quy định của tỏa của cao.